you just have to understand your
partner's lifestyle
do you guys care what job the girl that
you're the girls that you date have no
no just not athletes so what if she has
any friends as a job
i've been an only fans can we not do
that
if she's working like legitimately even
if i won't i won't judge
mcdonald's she's making money
at least you're working yeah you're
actually doing something here
for me i probably want you to aspire to
do more so it wouldn't just be just
working mcdonald's and that's what
you're doing and they'll be like what
else are you doing
with anything but
the job doesn't really get that get that
eight pound ninety five an
hour you know
that's all you've got
[Music]
yes
do you care what job a guy has
as long as you're doing yes for yourself
and there's nothing like crazy like you
no porn stuff no corn star sorry no
explicit stuff because at the end of the
day i'd rather keep that private would
you do you care if a guy's like broke
breaking more sense you can't be trying
to come out with me and
doing that chicken change like yeah i
mean i i feel comfortable in painful
food i'll pay for our food it's not
every single time because then i'm like
bro what what what's he doing
you know i don't like leeches have you
ever dated a leech
no no and if you could have no i don't i
like independent people yeah like people
that can take care of themselves yeah
what okay so what if he made it you can
take care of me as well what if he makes
like 30 000 a year is that okay
and i study you know that state yeah
that's nothing come on
the standards don't have to be like you
have to be running a mill like
like we actually have to be humble
people at the end of the day because we
are still all human
okay let's say you can't take you out
like all the time i'm saying like
you know how some guys like really take
the like they go over the top like look
like we're going hackathon today we're
going nobu
they just do too much
let's say they can't do that like what
do you say
well first of all i've never actually
been that's fair yeah but
like
but it's just like
um
i like quality time i like to feel like
if we can actually go to the park and
have a picnic have a good time and enjoy
ourselves
let's do that all right i don't feel
like let's look at something every
single day
because then you're building something
that you can't mention
do you ever feel like if a guy spends
money on you like too soon it turns you
off not not like a date but like where
he's like showering you like i've had
guys where they're like
nah i think that that sauce is not what
you want yeah that's that's how i felt
yeah what are you
after that what is it why would you do
that for me
[Music]
my last boyfriend my last boyfriend
would offer to send me like loads of
cash all the time i wouldn't take it
because i just feel like we were dating
he offered to send me like 10k once i
was just like you should have taken it
no i was freaking out
no i sort of got because i just i felt
weird taking money from someone i
would've took that in an instant that's
going towards my mortgage no because it
doesn't i know i i i still think about
it
i feel like if a guy does that he's just
trying to prove a point like oh yeah
he's a provider
let's be realistic uh i don't i don't
know what's of it so what about all your
friends are getting like
showered with gifts and they're just
like snapping they're putting on
instagram
why are they not getting gifts for me
no like from like the guy like the guy
they're dating like how would that make
you feel like if your guy was just
so let's say your guy can't do that like
he's still doing little things for you
but that's what you can't do you can't
do what they're doing so like
okay cool it's not for me but you know
what i mean
i would find a way
especially
where there's a way yeah for real but
then again it's like what girl doesn't
want to be shouted with gifts you know
that's true
i just i feel like too soon it turns me
off
no i swear to god because i'm like why
you know okay you know what's a weird
turn off i have this is really weird i
kind of i kind of have a thing for cheap
guys i don't know what it is like
okay because i love i don't know
watching i i love me a good bargain you
know yeah and so when i see guys spend
stupid amounts of money
on clothes
no and i'm just like
why like it doesn't impress me it makes
me think you're like like if you if you
only make so much money and you're
spending this much on your wardrobe i'm
like why no but it has to make sense
like if you have that lifestyle where
you can do that enjoy yourself in it
yeah that's what if it's not making
sense and you can't hear a phone bill we
are still dropping seven bills on the
shoes then we have a problem
no um first yeah yeah
yeah
just the expectations yes
imagine knocking on your boy's door with
a goose and balances i will pay for my
phone please i'll run about next month
now but it just goes back to socials bro
because you see on social media like you
see someone post like all these bags of
stuff and then
it's like
that's what you should be doing and in
reality it's not and there's people
there's so many people no it is it's so
it's women's fault
it's females
i say it's females football i wanted to
say that but i don't know those girls
will just be like
girls would be like if you ain't got a
goose he can't even approach me like she
wouldn't even look twice in your
direction
if he's not whipping don't catch him
like like like he's not even worried
about his phone bill like he's gonna add
her a snap and screenshot it because he
hasn't got data to like do what i mean
but he's going to have to use his
breadth he's got the goose to get the
snaps when he goes home in the world
just want to get the snap right there
yeah but those girls end up alone the
ones that are like he's got to do this
this this this and that like
i i always see those girls end up like
by their damn self often often it's the
really pretty girls though yeah that do
that it's so it's so sad often it's like
really like the girls are like the
nights girls like that these girls like
that you're that like you see like for
me you're like
these girls like that like you know so
just because like you're a 10-10 looks
you become like when when i see
something like you become like a 5 out
of 10 for me do you get it because it's
like
yeah you're lying and you have all the
looks and that but it's like just if
you're putting someone if you're putting
so much pressure for someone like bro
like
what are you doing for yourself type of
thing
like some girls because i can't
elaborate i'm a materialistic girl so
like
be ready to like be sharing with gifts
oh what do you bring to the table are me
it's your head i am the table yes like
what do you mean that and like with some
guys here and i think we're speaking
about this previously as well with some
guys because the girl was so
good-looking
like like
right if people see you everyone's like
wow he's not going to be doing things
just so he can keep the girl there yeah
so then he then becomes he starts doing
things that he doesn't need to do just
to make the girl happy so cool maybe by
the end of the month he might buy her
new v bag valencies dior's but he can't
even pay his phone bill he can't even
pay for get fulfilled saying i don't
like
and brood like as dawn said like
sometimes girls do you do that like it
does have a factor
yeah do you